the search is on for a suspect police
say shot a man during a robbery attempt
in chinatown that victim in critical
condition tonight after being shot
nearly a dozen times it happened at
about three o'clock this morning madison
kimbrough is live at shanghai taste
restaurant on spring mountain with more
details madison
described as a senseless and vicious act
the man a waiter here at shanghai taste
was trying to stop the attacker when he
was shot multiple times and now he's
fighting for his life
wang was already out front
on the ground in a puddle of blood so
and then the attacker
ran back out and ran this way he ran
north through the back and we don't know
where he went after that a startling
situation early monday morning as an
intruder broke into the shanghai taste
restaurant off of spring mountain a
waiter whose name is wang was cleaning
at the time he did his best to try to
stop the suspect but was shot 11 times
wang now is in critical condition at umc
those in the area say they've never seen
anything like this happen here this
place is
filled with people like all the time and
especially in the mornings too through
the afternoon so
and to have it here and
with a lot of
traffic around so it's
yeah that's shocking to hear and it's
pretty scary knowing that somebody would
even go to the lengths to do that and
for what something so petty it worries
me for my fellow co-workers and the
people in this plaza the suspect is
described as a black man last seen
wearing a blue hooded sweatshirt and
white shorts the owner of the restaurant
says he and the rest of his staff are
keeping weighing a main priority in all
of this moving forward right now the
only thing we care about
is that wang heals
fast and as healthy as possible we're
closing today we're closing tomorrow so
we could be with him
and shanghai taste plans to reopen on
wednesday and they plan to donate all
the proceeds they earn from the rest of
the year to wang and his family
reporting live madison kimbrough live
local now